along the Gulf Coast of the United
States federal and state authorities are
helping the region recover from one of
the largest oil spills in the planets
history and an important part of that
effort both environmentally and
economically is ensuring that the
seafood harvested from the Gulf of
Mexico is safe to eat the National
Oceanic and Atmospheric Administration
or NOAA along with the FDA and EPA is
overseeing the safety checks NOAA ships
catch fish and deliver them to the
national seafood inspection laboratory
in pass the Gullah Mississippi for
testing one of the tests involves a
low-tech way to analyze the food smell
NOAA's Steve Wilson heads the
inspections he says a nose can be very
discerning it could be construed that
it's nuanced but in fact it's very hard
science it's it's repeatable it's
statistical and with the proper training
very very verifiable so it's a good
science the lab has been testing gulf
fish samples for months researchers are
careful to identify each fish and where
it came from to ensure accurate tracking
of any contamination every individual
fish is wrapped in aluminum foil with a
label inside wrapped in garbage bags and
a label outside the inspections have
helped guide decisions to closed
portions of the Gulf to fishing and to
reopen others
more than 200 million gallons of oil
spilled into the Gulf of Mexico between
April and September at the peak of the
closures fishermen were prohibited from
more than a third of area waters about
13 percent of federal waters still
remain closed to fishing
in the lab researchers carefully cut
samples from each skinned fish some will
be frozen and shipped to another lab in
Seattle for chemical analysis others are
destined for the smell test at the
Pascagoula lab Wilson compares it to
wine tasters or other experts in food
industries he stresses the nose is
amazingly sensitive we can get them
sensitive to one parts per million
contamination in the seafood product
this is not that easy even the experts
sometimes get a false positive or a
false negative
so you to deal with that we have a panel
and it's the panel results of the
individual expertise in the statistical
reliability of the panel as a number
that make the difference on Wilson says
the chemical lab tests are highly
accurate and may be more sensitive than
smell but the nose can catch things that
technology may miss if the sensory looks
at the combination the the acceptability
unacceptability difference from normal
they look at the whole picture chemistry
would in fact pick on specific compounds
and in explain their levels not
necessarily acceptable or unacceptable s
you've set a mark
so far seafood coming out of the Gulf
has been deemed safe but the public's
fear of contamination hits seafood
markets and fishermen hard unless
consumers trust that commercial
fishermen are providing a clean catch
the stigma attached to Gulf seafood may
last for a while
you